let's talk about this film hearts beat
loud yes very nice very nice a very nice
relationship you explain a little bit of
the plot because it's very nice Rich Dad
yeah I'm a single dad I'm a widower and
my daughter is getting ready to go away
to college we and we play music together
we have since she was a kid
and it suddenly gets very good and that
becomes the conflict she's supposed to
go across the country to medical school
he's a good student she's got a real
yeah she wants to be responsible and I'm
like blow that off let's have a rock
band together yeah listen to your father
for once yeah and and it's a it's a
beautiful movie with so much heart and
in this time I don't know if you've seen
the news but sometimes it will bum you
out and with that going on in the
country it's just this really nice dose
of medicine about acceptance and and
loving the people in your home and
finding out you know and finding out if
you can have a career as a rock star
mm-hmm
or not don't give any spoilers well
let's take a look at this clip from
hearts beat loud I hope you with
something or yeah are you not watching
the clock it's jam sesh time yeah come
on come on givin jams made for a long
time please know I'm doing something
right now I understand when jam sesh
time arrives we have to put aside
childish things like homework and med
schools don't touch my things when it's
time for jam sesh that's a good dad
you